Ja, bitte schön.
Okay.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ustlau. Ich bin die Ensaabende Arsi, Alftuzaristation.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschichte für den Istas okay für Sie.
Ja, sicher. Darf ich mir noch einmal Ihren Namen bitte?
Ja, Ust Betül, Ustlau Ogulları. Mein Name ist Ust.
Und ich werde erst Ihre persönliche Daten aufnehmen. Dann komme ich gleich zu Ihren aktuellen Becher.
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Irma Claus.
Irma Claus. Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vorunternamen büstenbieren?
Ja, I-R-M-A ist der Vorannahme.
Okay.
Und der Familienname ist Claus K-L-A-U-S, wie der männliche Vorname.
Okay. Herrsch.
Frau Irma ist eine Frau.
Ja, ja. Frau Claus, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 37 Jahre.
Okay, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 13.785.
85, gut.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, 69 kg wiegen ich zurzeit.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
68 kg.
Ja, Herr Claus.
Frau Claus.
Wie kann ich Ihnen heißen? Was für eine Schwerthabenside.
Ja, ich habe so heftige Bauchschmerzen.
Und zwar, ich seid gestern Abend nach dem Essen, fügen das an.
Und also ich kann mich wirklich so kaum halten, vor Schmerzen.
Das ging los.
Und so unmittelbar im Bauch.
Und dann ist mir schlecht geworden.
Und die Schmerzen sind immer schlimmer geworden.
Und jetzt ist es mehr so im Unterbauch die Schmerzen.
Und einmal musste ich mich übergeben.
Aber schlecht ist mir die ganze Zeit.
Und ich habe dann also in der Nacht nicht gut geschlafen.
Also mir ist es wirklich sehr schlecht auf Unterschmerzen.
Okay, ja.
Frau Claus, wo sind die Schmerzen jetzt?
Um rechten Bauch oder rechten Unterrahmbauch
oder linken Unterrahmbauch?
Die sind mehr im rechten Unterrahmbauch.
Ja.
Und das Sticht so.
Es ist ganz unangenehm.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen gestern Abend?
Gestern Abend ist das losgegangen.
Nach dem Abendessen hat es angefangen.
Dann dachte ich erst, ich habe vielleicht etwas Verkehrtes gegessen.
Aber Durchfall oder so etwas habe ich jetzt nicht gehabt.
Aber das tut richtig doll weh.
Ja, ich habe nicht mehr gegessen.
Aber ich habe nicht mehr gegessen.
Sicherlich, weil sieben oder sechs ist ein wirklich starkes Schmerz.
Okay.
Frau Claus, habe Sie etwas einigen genommen?
Nein, ich habe nichts einigen genommen.
Ich habe dann versucht, einen Schluck schwarzen Teel zu trinken.
Und dann habe ich versucht mit einer Wärmflasche abhüllen.
Aber das hat auch nichts gebracht.
Und ja, es ist immer schlimmer geworden.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Claus, ich kann Ihnen vielleicht einen Schmerz mitteiligen.
Aber ich empfehle Ihnen, bis zum Unserergespräch,
bis Ende Unserergespräch,
können Sie dieses Schmerz erhalten.
Vielleicht, wenn Sie Ihnen einen Schmerz tabletten,
das kann meine Unterrichtung wirken.
Deswegen empfehle ich keine Schmerz tabletten.
Das wird ja nicht so lange dauern.
Ja, ja, ja, unserergespräch nicht so lange dauert.
Und denken Sie, gibt es bei uns noch ein Sonderes?
Nein, ich dachte ja, das wäre das Abendessen.
Aber wie gesagt, da vereine ich nichts Besonderes.
Was haben Sie gegessen?
Ich habe ganz normal ein bisschen Salat, ein bisschen Brot mit Käse
und Glasspudeln getrunken und nachher eben den Tee getrunken.
Aber es ist nicht besser geworden.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen eher dumpf oder krampfartig oder stechend?
Wie bewertet?
Das Krampf und es ist sticht, wirklich.
Das ist sticht.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen Sie wieder weg?
Nein, nein, die sind eigentlich ständig da.
Ständig, okay.
Haben Sie diese Beschwerde schon einmal erlebt?
Oder ist es...
So was habe ich noch nicht gehabt.
Ja, also klar hat man sich mal den Magen verdorben,
dann hat man hinterher Durchfall und dann wusch, ist das alles raus
und dann geht es dann besser.
Aber jetzt...
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam begonnen?
Die sind plötzlich aufgetreten, ja.
Okay, ja, Frau Atlas, ich würde gerne auch wissen.
Ja, ich würde gerne auch wissen.
Sie haben keine Duschfein, aber Sie haben Probleme bei...
Bitte?
Sie haben Probleme bei Basalas?
Nein.
Keine Probleme. Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Normal ist ja gut, aber jetzt kann ich natürlich gar nichts essen,
weil ich solche Bauchschmerzen habe.
Okay.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Angeblich verloren oder...
Ne, da hat sich nichts geändert.
Das ist ja ziemlich stabil, doch, ja.
Haben Sie eine Hautfarbe-Eränderung zum Beispiel...
Die Änderung der Hautfarbe.
Hautfarbe, Hautfarbe...
Ne, da hat sich nichts...
Nichts.
Nichts geändert.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich glaube wohl, also ich fühle mich fieberig,
aber ich habe jetzt nicht gemessen,
aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich so ein bisschen heiß bin, ja.
Okay, fieberig.
Okay.
Sind diese Schmerzen abhängig von Sitzern stehen
oder laufen?
Ja, wenn ich mich so ein bisschen zusammenbeuge,
so krumm mache, dann habe ich das Gefühl,
kann ich es besser aushalten,
als wenn ich gerade liege.
Also ich habe jetzt auf der Seite gelegen im Bett
und so die Knie angezogen, da hatte ich das Gefühl,
dass ich das wenigstens aushalten kann.
Aber so stramm, gerade liegen, ging mich gut.
Okay.
Gibt es bestimmte Sachen, was sich verschlechtert?
Ja, natürlich, gerade wenn ich liegen.
Okay.
Und ich weiß ja, ich habe jetzt natürlich nicht viel gemacht.
Ich bin ja dann jetzt heute morgens gleich zu Ihnen gekommen.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was das Verschlechtert noch.
Okay.
Gegen fiebergefühl haben Sie etwas gemacht?
Ja, ich habe mich halt ins Bett gelegt,
aber sonst habe ich nichts gemacht.
Nein.
Okay.
Ja, leiden Sie an irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Ich bin nicht gesund, ich bin ja eine junge Frau.
Also dann habe ich eigentlich nichts.
Was Sie natürlich wissen sollten,
dass ich eine Schildrüse unterfunktion habe.
Ja, das ist klar, da muss ich immer so Schildrüse Tabletten nehmen.
Wissen Sie die Namen?
Das heißt irgendwie Tyroxin.
Okay.
Wissen Sie Dosierung?
Nee, das weiß ich nicht.
Das weiß ich nicht auch im Kopf.
Ich habe noch keine Pausenzettel.
Okay, nehmen Sie sonst die Gemetikamente,
oder gerne Sie kann?
Nein.
Eigentlich nehme ich nur diese Schildrüse Tabletten.
Und ja, manchmal wenn ich so ein bisschen Magenprobleme habe,
wenn ich mal etwas nicht vertragen habe,
dann nehme ich mal so Pantoprazol,
das hat mir mein Arzt mal gegeben,
das nehme ich nur gelegenlich.
Okay.
Hast du mal ein Schleim oder eine Sündung?
Nein, aber ich hatte mal so eine Phase,
wo ich ein bisschen Magen beschwerden hatte.
Und da hat der Arzt mir das mal gegeben.
Okay.
Wollt du uns ein bisschen operieren?
Nein, ich hatte bisher noch keine Operation.
Doch als Kind, natürlich, die Mandeln habe ich rausgekommen.
Schon so lange her, dass ich das gar nicht mehr im Kopf habe.
Klar, als Kind, die Mandeln sind operiert.
Haben Sie Allergie?
Das sind nicht die, die uns allergisch stimmen.
Nein.
Okay.
Und, äh, rauchen Sie Fragen?
Nein, nein, nein, ich rauche nicht.
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol, Regeln, Messig oder gelegenlich?
Gelegenlich trinke ich mal ein Glas Wein, aber wirklich sehr selten.
Okay.
Seit wann trinken Sie?
Ach ja, wann trinken, fängt man an mit dem Alkohol?
Ja, was, was ich so mit 16, 17, da hat man vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen mehr getrunken,
aber jetzt, seit ich erwachsen bin.
Okay.
Kann ich mir das gar nicht erlauben?
Nehmen Sie diese Frage, nicht perlöschen.
Das ist eine reine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit dem Drogen?
Mit Drogen?
Ne, mit Drogen habe ich keine Erfahrung.
Gut, ja.
Und, äh, in Ihrer Familie gibt es wichtige Vorerkrankungen,
bei dem Vater, bei dem Mutter oder?
Ja, mein Vater, der hatte irgendwie mit einem Mitte-60-en-Herzen-Fakt,
aber hat sich danach wieder ja ganz gut erholt und meine Mutter ist eigentlich gesund.
Geht gut, gut.
Okay, Gott sei Dank.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Eine Schwester habe ich ja.
Und die ist tatsächlich nicht gesund.
Da hat man jetzt vor zwei Jahren eine ältere Schwester,
die hat Burstkrebs.
Okay, ist das eine Behandlung oder?
Sie ist natürlich, klar, sie ist in Behandlung und gilt jetzt im Augenblick als stabilisiert,
aber es ist natürlich so etwas, was über einem schwebt.
Ja, ja, ich kann das gar stehen.
Was machen Sie beruflich für eine Klasse?
Ja, ich arbeite Teilzeit bei einer Versicherung.
Und ansonsten bin ich Hausv und habe zwei Kinder, die noch in die Schule gehen.
Ja, okay.
Und Sie haben zwei Kinder?
Sie sind beide gesund oder?
Sie beiden Kinder sind gesund, ja, ja.
Sie sind verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Wie geht es mit den Kindern?
Ja, mit den Kindern gehe ich hier raus und ansonsten fahre ich auch viel Fahrrad.
Okay.
Ja, frage ich mich.
Wie hat es sich mit dem Problem verheiratet?
Nein, da habe ich keine Probleme.
Regelblutung ist ja ziemlich regelmäßig.
Nein, ich möchte jetzt eigentlich nur, dass diese Schmerzen aufhören
und dass ich mich irgendwo hinlegen kann,
dass es irgendwie besser wird.
Ja, und ja, das wäre jetzt gut.
Ja, erst möchte ich Ihnen bedanken.
Sie haben gut diese Schmerzenertrag.
Aber jetzt werde ich Ihnen ein paar Untersuchungen dünnchen.
Ich habe eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Natürlich.
Nachdem alle Untersuchungen ergeten ist, kann ich das mir sagen.
Fragestellung.
Ja, ich habe auch einen Behandlung
dünnchen.
Dann gehst du wieder besser.
Okay.
Geht es?
Ja.
Okay.
Und meine andere Frage.
Ich habe ein Tag gestern.
Meine Kollegen haben geschrieben,
strahlende Schmerzenirgenfolien aus.
Medikstrahlen nicht aus.
Die sind nur vom Mittelbau gewandert in den Unterbau.
Aber ausstrahlen im eigentlichen Sinne tun sie nicht.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestattet.
Noch haben Kollegen Fragen.
Als das geschieht, können wir anfangen.
Ja.
Schön.
Okay.
Okay, ja.
Ja.
Guten Tag Frau Oberarztin.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patient nachgenommen.
Ich möchte Ihnen diese Patientin vorstellen.
Hättest du sie dafür satt?
Ja, wesentlich.
Ja.
Es handelt sich um 20.
Sie ist 30 Jahre alt, 9,6 Kilogramm schwer.
1,8 Meter groß.
Er kam heute wegen,
gestern ab 5.
Händler,
strahlende Krampfartiger,
strahlender Schmerzenin unteren
Ober- und Rechtsunterbau.
Ohne Ausstrahlung zu uns.
Und
die Patienten berichten,
dass die Schmerzen
erst im Mittelbau begonnen haben,
dann zu unteren Rechtsunterbau gewandert sein.
Und er klackte
auf Mesis einmal
und Nozia.
Und er habe keine Appetit wegen aktueller Beschwerde.
Er habe...
Ist das jetzt so Frau oder Mann?
Frau.
Sie hat zuerst mal diese Beschwerde erledigt.
Und die Schmerzen auflegen,
auf einer Schmerzskala
bei 6,7.
Bei dem Büchern
zahlt die Schmerzen
besser geworden.
Sie fühle sich ständig für die Pflege,
aber sie habe das viel bei uns gemessen.
Er berichtete auch,
die Schmerzen plötzlich
nach dem Essen...
gestern abends nach dem Essen aufgetreten.
Aufgetreten.
Ja, und die Frage nach weiteren Beschwerden
wurde verneint.
Als für Erkrankungen
leidete sie Hypothriose
und dagegen
Neime sie etroxin nur einmal.
Die Dosierung ist nicht erinnerlich.
Und sie habe auch abends
mal Probleme, mal Schmerzen
und dagegen Neime erbeiden
von Panthoprosol.
Sie ist als Kind
tonsillektimiert worden.
Und die
genokologische Anämenese ist unaufwählich.
Ja, in der Familienanämenese
fand es sich im Yokartinfarkt
vertreten,
und seine Schwester
leide an Mama karslo.
Und sie ist deswegen in Behandlung.
Er...
Schuldigung, sie ist nicht traurig.
Sie trinkt ab und zu
Englischwein.
Und die Frage nach Drogen
wurde verneint.
Sie habe keine Allergie
oder unsere Erträglichkeit.
Ja, aufgrund der
Anämenestation Angaben
gehe ich von
Apandesitis aus.
Als Differenzialdiagnose
käme
auch Neapolitiasis
oberian Torsion
und
Ektopic
Ektopicpregnancy
in Betracht.
Ah!
Ja, sagen Sie mal,
sagen Sie mal auf Lateinisch.
Ja,
extrauterin Schwangerschaft.
Ja, extrauterin Gravidität, ne?
Ja, genau.
Haben Sie nach letzter Regel gefragt
oder auf die Möglichkeit einer Schwangerschaft?
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Ich habe nur
haben Sie Probleme bei meiner Gelbültung gefragt.
Ich habe keine Probleme mit meiner Gelbültung.
Ja, aber
das fragen
bei der Frau
die Frage.
Mhm.
Gut. Was käme noch an
an
Differenzialdiagnosen in Frage?
Ich habe
Neapolitiasis
es kann sein,
die Artikulitis
nochmal.
Die Artikulitis
ja, die Artikulitis
und
ja, Akkutskulitis
könnte sein, aber ja.
Ja, also
den Bauch muss man natürlich angucken.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Ja, erst
werde ich
warte ich sich körperlich unterzucken.
Worauf achten Sie da besonders?
Ja, besonders
beim der Patient hat
sie hat beim
Positives
Makbuny Zeichen
das ist eine
Druckschmerzen mit
Abwehrspannung
in der
auf der rechten Unterbau
und
ja, ich kontrolliere
diese Zeichen und vielleicht
eine
vaginal und
digitalerektal
und auch
auch könnte sein.
Ja,
ja,
ja, und ich auskulpziere
den Bauch, um den
Darmgeräusch zu hören.
Ja,
und
es gibt auch weitere Zeichen,
RovSync,
vielleicht
der Bauch ist wichtig,
Druckschmerzen, Abwehrspannung
und
Losplatzschmerzen.
Ja, genau.
Und was würden Sie dann
operativ machen?
Als operative Therapie
werde ich erst
Nein, nicht Therapie,
Untersuchung.
Ja, ich würde sagen,
als operative Untersuchung
werde ich
erst abdominal
Ultrasonografie durchführen.
Ja, da würde man
sicherlich eine Menge schon sehen.
Ja.
Ich kann
auch
Infektion, Zeichen,
Imperation
des Attendissitis
bemerken, als auch
weitere
Diagnose
als
ja, genau.
Und ja, als
Gegeben
Fall
von
Appendicitis
würde ich
Freeram
falls
würde ich auch
Abdominal CT
Gegeben
Ja, ich meine
wenn es nicht eindeutig ist, ne?
Ja,
Was machen die Labortechnisch?
Beim Labor ist wichtig,
Blutbild, CRP,
Blutsenkung, Geschwindigkeit,
Colestus,
Levelparameter
Abbüroding
Tarsuchung.
Und ich erwarte
bei
Laboruntersuchung
Erwarte
Infektion, Zeichen
Ja, klar.
Ja, und auch
Erwarte
Blutsenkung, Geschwindigkeit und CRP
Ja, und
aufweilige
Üren,
vielleicht Ürenuntersuchung
Erwarte ich, ja.
Okay.
Und
wenn sich das jetzt bestätigt
und wir operieren müssen,
wann hat die Patientin zuletzt gegessen?
Ja
Sie hat immer
Nose
und so lässt
ich habe
diese Frage nicht direkt gestalt,
aber ich vermute
sie hat
so letzt am
gestern Abend etwas gegessen.
Dann hätten wir auf alle Fälle die 6 Stunden
extra
voran erkundet.
Ja
Ja,
vor der Operasion
würde ich auch
operative
Verbereitung
einige Blutuntersuchung
düşführen.
Ja, und
empfehle
ich erst
erst
als
bei den Patienten
ausreichende Flüssigkeit
Antibiotikum,
Antibiotischer Therapie
Ja, aber
wie kriegt sie die Flüssigkeit?
Flüssigkeit
Wie kriegt sie die?
Sie soll ja nicht essen oder trinken.
Ja
Sie
müssen nicht, Sie sollen nicht essen
oder trinken
vor der
Operasion
und deswegen
Flüssigkeit geben.
Ja, wie geben Sie die Flüssigkeit?
Was müssen Sie machen?
Ja, intravenöse
Flüssigkeit.
Sie müssen Zugänge legen.
Wenn Sie die aufgenommen haben, müssen Sie
erst mal Zugänge legen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich werde
Zugänge legen
und ausreichende
Flüssigkeit führen
und
dann antibiotische Therapie
werde ich begehen.
Und auch empfehle
eine laparoscopische
Operationen.
Ja, sehr gut.
Okay, gut.
Ja, dann halten Sie mich
auf dem Lauffenden,
dass es jetzt noch ein bisschen klauzlos ist.
Wie es ihr geht,
was tatsächlich dahinter steckt.
Gucken Sie auf alle Fälle
nochmal, ob ihr nicht vielleicht
irgendwie
unbemerkt schwanger ist
und
zur Verhütung hat sie nichts gesagt.
Zur Verhütung
hat sie nichts gesagt.
Ja, ja, ich habe nicht gepragt.
Ja.
Ja, also kann man ja auch
in der Hand schwanger werden.
Und
das wäre
tatsächlich eine Möglichkeit.
Aber wahrscheinlich
ist ja,
dass sie tatsächlich die Appendizide hat.
Ja.
Gut.
Und wenn es so was ist,
dass Sie in den U-Pay gehen,
dann sagen Sie mir bitte Bescheid.
Okay, danke schön.
Alles klar.
Ja.
Okay.
Im Vergleich zum letzten Mal
waren Sie heute sprachlich
nicht so gut
unterwegs.
Sie
haben
also im
in den
Fragen
es ist mir aufgefallen
habe ich mir nur kurz natiert
können Sie
die Schmerzen erhalten haben Sie gefragt.
Sie müssen natürlich
können Sie die Schmerzen aushalten
oder ertragen.
Entweder ertragen
oder aushalten.
Dann
war
stimmt ein einige Artikel nicht so richtig.
Genau.
Auf der
auf der rechten unteren Bauch.
Ja, also
die Schmerzen sind
in den rechten unteren Bauch gewandert.
Da
ja, das
gestern
die letzten Mal Dienstag war
irgendwie
sprachlich ein bisschen
ein bisschen fitter und ein bisschen besser.
Verständigung.
Ja, ein paar Mal habe ich nachgefragt.
Haben Sie gemerkt.
Und
das war
ein bisschen besser.
Und
also
von der
Fachterminologie
überhaupt kein Problem.
Sie können
alles erklären
und Sie können alle
Fachfragen mit den richtigen
Sachen beantworten.
Das ist eigentlich nur so diese Alltagssprache
wo sie ein bisschen Probleme haben.
Und
wo es dann
einfach nicht so glatt klingt.
Vielleicht
hören Sie sich
noch mal an
mit kritischen Ohren
dass Sie noch mal hören
wo habe ich denn da Fehler gemacht.
Ja.
Ich weiß immer gar nicht wie das geht.
Ich kann die Dinge gar nicht abrufen.
Und
ich kann auch nicht die ganze Zeit immer mit schreiben.
Aber
also heute ist es mir auch gefallen,
dass es
formal nicht so
nicht so toll war.
Müssen wir noch ein bisschen dran arbeiten.
Ja.
Viel deutsche Texte lesen.
Auch laut lesen.
Und
suchen Sie das Gespräch,
wann immer Sie können.
Suchen Sie das Gespräch
mit Muttersprachlern
mit Deutschen
Stichwort beim Einkaufen
oder bei irgendwas.
Dass Sie richtiges Deutsch hören.
Okay.
Es ist, je nachrichten hören, Radio hören,
Tagesschau angucken,
also so die seriösen
Sachen.
Da hören Sie die richtige Sprache.
Und
das kann man gar nicht oft genug hören
als dass man
das dann eben
übt
in den richtigen Verlauf
so langsam aufnimmt.
Okay.